c'est non aussi une émission de radio
funny pour déranger même moment ça
s'appelle les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire
[Musique]
et il en notre temps rien de plus odieux
de plus désespérant de plus scandaleux
que de ne pas croire en la démocratie
et pourtant pourtant moi même quand on
me demandait de vous démocrate je me
tape attitude révélatrice dans la mesure
où face à la gravité de ce genre de
question la décence voudrait plutôt que
l'on sait ça de se tâter un ami
royalistes me faisait récemment
remarquer que la démocratie était la
pire des dictatures
parce qu'elle est la dictature exercée
par le plus grand nombre sur la minorité
mais oui réfléchissez-y une seconde
c'est pas idiot
pensez-y avant de reprendre
inconsidérément la bastille alors quand
monarchie en monarchie absolue notamment
la loi du prince refuse cette attitude
discriminatoire puisqu'elle est la même
pour les pour et pour les contres vous
me direz que cela ne justifie pas qu'on
aille dépoussiérer les bâtards d'orléans
ou ramasser les débris de bourbon pour
les poser sur le trône de france avec la
couronne au front le sceptre à la main
il à plumes ou vous voudrez je ne sais
pas faire les bouquets mais convenez
avec moi que ce mépris constitutionnel
des minorités qui caractérise les
régimes démocratiques peut surprendre le
penseur humaniste qui sommeille chez
tous cochon régicide
d'autant plus que paradoxe les
intellectuels démocrates les plus
sincères n'ont souvent plus d'autre but
quand ils font partie de la majorité
élue que d'essayer à tout prix
d'appartenir à une minorité dans les
milieux dits artistique où le souci que
j'ai de nourrir ma famille me pousse
encore trop souvent à sucer des joues
dans les cocktails sur un temps de faux
amour on rencontre des brassées de
démocrates militants qui préférait
crever plutôt que d'être plus de 12
avoir compris le dernier godard et qui
méprise suprêmement le troupeau de leurs
électeurs qui se presse aux belles
monderie boulevardière parce que ça
aussi c'est la démocratie la démocratie
c'est la victoire de belmondo sur
fellini
c'est aussi l'obligation pour ceux qui
n'aiment pas ça de subir à longueur
d'antenne le football et les embrassades
poilus de ces cro magnon décérébrés
qu'on a vu ce éclaté de rire sur le
charnier de leurs supporters la
démocratie c'est aussi la loi du top 50
et des mamadou centre converti en dons
dont ilan hier la démocratie c'est quand
lubitsch mozart rené char reiser ou les
batailles hommes de chez polak ou
n'importe quoi d'autre qu'on puisse
soupçonner même de loin d'intelligence
est reportée à la mi nuit pour que la
majorité puisse s'émerveiller dès 20h30
en rotant son fromage du soir sur le
spectacle irréel d'un bea trentenaire
figé dans un sourire définitif de figues
éclaté et offrant des automobiles clés
en main à des pauvres s arthritiques
sans défense est dépourvu de permis de
conduire
cela dit en cherchant bien on finit par
trouver au régime démocratique
quelques avantages sur les seules autres
régimes qui lui font victorieusement
concurrence dans le monde actuellement
ceux-ci semblables de la schlague en
bottes noires ou du goulag rouge étoilé
d'abord dans l'un comme dans l'autre
au lieu de vous agacer tous les soirs
entre les oreilles je fermerai ma gueule
en attendant la soupe dans ma cellule
aseptisé et puis aussi dans l'un comme
dans l'autre
chez les drapeaux rouges comme chez les
chemises noires les chefs eux mêmes ont
rarement le droit de sortir tout seul le
soir pour aller au cinéma du coin bras
dessus bras dessous avec la femme qu'ils
aiment les chefs des drapeaux rouges et
les chefs des chemises noires ne vont
copa cinglant de leurs bottes guerrière
le torse pris dans un corset de fer à
l'épreuve de l'amour et des balles ils
vont tragique et le flingue sur le coeur
ils vont métalliques et la peur au
ventre vers les palais blindés ou
s'ordonne leurs lois de glace ils
marchent droit sous leurs casquettes
leurs yeux durs sous verres fumés cerné
de vin gorille pare chocs qui surveille
les toits pour repérer la mort mais la
mort n'est pas pour les chefs des
drapeaux rouges ni pour les chefs des
chemises noires
la mort n'est pas aux fenêtres des
rideaux de fer elle a trop peur la mort
et sur stockholm
elle signe d'un trait rouge sur la neige
blanche son aveu d'impuissance à tuer la
liberté des hommes qui vont au cinéma
tout seul bras dessus bras dessous avec
la femme qu'ils aiment
jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
[Musique]